somebody on Twitter asked put this
question out there for everyone what
advice would you give to your teenage
self and so I know exactly what advice I
would give I would say to my teenage
self invent the Snuggie which is just a
blanket with arms make a couple of
million bucks off of that invested in
Netflix and Amazon stock and then go
build a compound in the wilderness and
drop off the grid for good because
things are going to get pretty weird and
you might want to avoid it as best you
can all right the the March for Life is
is happening today in DC which is why
I'm wearing my make unborn babies great
again shirt hundreds of thousands of
pro-lifers taken to the street calling
for an end to abortion that's what's
happening right now
the hideous evil of abortion is what
they're standing up against now it's not
going to get anywhere close to the kind
of media coverage of course that
literally any other March of this size
would get and has gotten which by the
way is a very small category so when I
say marches of this size that's there
there aren't very many other marches
that fit into that into that category
there have rarely in American history
been marches the size of just your
average ordinary annual March for life
the so-called women's March a few years
back now that may have been around the
same size but and think about all the
media coverage that thing got but that
was one March that was just one time
they couldn't sustain it and the
incredible thing about the March for
Life is that they do this every year
year after year urine you're out for
40-plus years and Counting and there is
always a huge turnout every single time
and they do it in the winter too okay
they do it in the dead of winter where
it's very cold a lot of times there's
snow on the ground like there is now and
there's ice if they move the March to
like April or May and they also didn't
have competing marches because that's
the other thing there are other marches
other marches for life
around the country in other cities some
today some at other points in January so
if if they were boiled down with two one
March and then do it in April or do it
in May I think they could easily get a
million people or more but even with
those disadvantages they still they
still get hundreds of thousands of
people now I'm not gonna not going to
give you a whole speech about the March
you've heard it before for me you also
you already know how I feel about the
March for Life and you know how I feel
about the aims of the March for Life but
there's just there's there's one thing
about the March for Life that I wanted
to I just want to highlight you know I
wanted you to notice it's really obvious
thing but it's easy to overlook and this
is this is the the profound thing that
separates the march from for life from
pretty much any other kind of march
aside from the turn out the other thing
that separates it is this nobody is
there to march for themselves okay
nobody is demanding anything for
themselves just think about that nobody
not one single person if there are three
hundred thousand four hundred thousand
five hundred thousand people the March
not a single one of them is gonna be
there marching for their own rights
because everybody marching has already
been born if we're not counting the you
know the many pregnant women that are
gonna be there with with babies in the
womb so all the people who made the
choice to get into a car or a bus and
drive to the March they're marching
there there they are there for others
okay they're there for those who cannot
be there in any other kind of march that
you can think of it's always people
there for the most part now there may be
some people will show up who are you
know there to support and but for the
most part predominantly and any other
kind of march the people there are
saying I want my rights I want respect
for me and dignity and whatever else for
myself and there's nothing wrong
with that if the cause is just then
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with marching for your own
rights it's a good thing to do an
American thing to do the problem of
course with the women's March is that
they weren't marching for their own
rights because they already women
already have to the exclusion of unborn
females um women already have all the
same rights as men so they weren't
marching for I already have all the
rights what they wanted was you know
like free birth control knows guys they
said they were demanding things that are
not rights they were in demanding extra
entitlements so that so that is an
unjust cause but there are plenty of
other rights and demonstrations that
have happened throughout history
throughout American history where the
cause was just and it's good that people
came to demand their rights but in this
case you know the people who are being
deprived of their rights cannot March
for obvious reasons so others are there
in their place and here's the other
powerful thing despite what you may be
told and I want you to if you're if
you're if you can't make it out to the
March if you're not gonna be there after
the March has happened try to find some
footage of it it's gonna be kind of
difficult to find actual footage of the
March because the the mainstream media
they're not going to show you now they
might mention it they might make a quick
mention of Oh anti-abortion
demonstrators are in DC or what that
what they like to say is something like
people are in DC today demonstrating on
either side of the abortion and the
abortion issue meanwhile there are
400,000 pro lifers and like 10
pro-abortion people and the mainstream
media will portray it as if it's kind of
an even split right but what they won't
do they won't show you a huge kind of
panoramic view of all the people who
showed up they're not going to show you
that so it might be hard to find it but
if you go to black pro-life sites live
site news or something like that you can
find it and I would I would recommend or
go on social media go on Twitter and
look at the pictures because what you're
going to notice is that despite what
you're told you
not a bunch of old white men there who
are trying to control women's bodies now
that there are gonna be some old white
men which great god bless them they are
needed in the movement as well but most
of the participants in the march for
life and most pro-life activists in
general are younger and most are women
so these are young women predominantly
so think about that not only are these
young women marching for others aside
from themselves but they're marching
demanding laws that would in a sense
restrict their own legal rights okay
they are marching demanding laws that
would deprive themselves of certain
legal powers that they currently possess
so they're saying no why is these women
who march in marks life what they're
saying is no I should not have the right
or the ability or the power to take
innocent life I should not have that
right that is not a real human right I
shouldn't have it take it from me and in
exchange give basic human dignity and
human rights to the unborn now that is a
that's a really powerful message isn't
it think about that much think about how
unprecedented it is for a message like
that especially in this day and age when
people are constantly prattling on about
rights they don't have you know they
have all the rights in the world and now
they want more than want entitlements
they want this they want that but these
women who are at the march for life and
women in the pro-life movement generally
they are saying exactly the opposite
they're saying yes I want all of my
god-given human rights but the right to
kill child that is not a god-given human
right I should not have that right take
it away give it to give rights to the
child what a what a powerful beautiful
message and as I said unprecedented all
right
let's talk about something a little less
inspiring representative Omar who's a
Democrat is making insinuations about
Senator Lindsey Graham now it's
important just for some background
reference here just so you understand
how despicable this is the thing that
we're talking about is there has long
been a rumor in DC that Lindsey Graham
is gay okay a rumor as in it's just
something that his political enemies
will will sometimes say or insinuate
it's just an implication whispers right
I'm not aware of there being any truth
to it or basis for it whatsoever at all
but you need to know that this rumor
exists so that you can understand what
the Democrats are doing here so a guy
named Kasim Rashid calls himself an
Islamic educator said on Twitter this
week in reaction to Lindsey Graham's
kind of change of tone about Donald
Trump over the past few years Rashid
said I can't even imagine what they have
on Graham now there's an obvious
implication there if you're aware of the
rumors and you say well I can't imagine
what they might have on him it's really
obvious what you're trying to imply and
then representative Omar a Democrat
sitting member of Congress she responds
with her own tweet and she says they got
to him he is compromised so that's not
even like she's saying her opinion or
she's presenting this as a theory she
said no they got to him he is
compromised what does she mean by that
well she was pressed on this by CNN CNN
did a rare bit of actual journalism
actually pressing a Democrat and here's
how that conversation went
that's quite a charge to make you say
you're pretty sure based on based on
what evidence what what facts that
that's a remarkable comment to make
about a sitting u.s. senator the the the
evidence really is present to us it's
being presented to us in the way that
he's believing
but that's not evidence that that's your
opinion but now is a sitting member of
Congress you would have tweeted they got
him on this again just based on what
evidence congresswoman my my tweet was
just an opinion based on what I believe
to be visible to me and I'm pretty sure
there are lots of Americans who agree on
this now so she's you see there she's
trying to backpedal a little bit and
sort of she's trying to leave the
insinuation sort of dangling out there
for people to so they know it and
understand it but she's not but that's
the point of the insinuation she's not
gonna say it she's not gonna come right
out and say it because she's also a
coward
meanwhile MSNBC anchor Stephanie ruhle
has gotten in on the act as well here
she is on MSNBC a couple of days ago
kind of feeding into this to this rumor
as well before Donald Trump got elected
Lindsey Graham called Donald Trump a
racist xenophobic bigot that is Lindsey
Graham's words I doubt Lindsey Graham
could tell you Donald Trump's had a
change of heart in the last 24 months I
bet what the change of heart has been
with Lindsey Graham not the President or
it could be that Donald Trump or
somebody knows something pretty extreme
about Lindsey Graham okay so you see how
this goes right
liberals spend all day insisting that
all lifestyles are great and equal and
and wonderful and they should all be
accepted and so on but then they will
not hesitate to imply that a person is
gay in order to insult or discredit them
and they do this all the time with
conservatives not just with with Lindsey
Graham but any conservative who stands
up for Biblical marriage or talks about
this issue at all what you're gonna hear
from from liberals is oh you know I bet
he's hiding something yeah he you know
we all know we all know what's going on
with that guy which of course is
ridiculous for a number of reasons but
anyway so what if he is hiding something
that should be a total non story right
to you as a liberal it should be a
non-issue to you so you're implying that
Lindsey Graham is gay well that's well
that's a that is a libelous despicable
thing to do to make implications with
someone with no evidence or anything
like that to feed into rumors but even
aside from that what what does it matter
to you you you that should be a
non-issue non-story to you and not only
that but if somebody were gay and they
were hiding it for whatever reason then
you should respect their right to to
what to come out with win and how and if
they choose right but that's not what
happens and this is even leaving aside
by the way this whole thing with Linds
ago this this idea he's being
blackmailed or you know what's going off
Lindsey Graham changed his tune he was
against Trump now he's for him actually
Lindsey Graham has I mean Lindsey Graham
came out against Trump yesterday because
of the letter that Trump said to Pelosi
cancelling her travel plans which I
thought that letter was great by the way
at hilarious Lindsey Graham came out
against it and said it was sophomore I
cannae like it so so look I disagree
with Lindsey Graham a lot but it does
appear to me for the most part he just
he just calls it as he sees it so he's
come out strongly against Japanese and
he's and he's strongly defended him and
if you're trying to figure out well why
is he against him here and for could it
maybe just be that he agrees with Trump
on this issue and not on that issue and
I respect that even if I disagree with
where Graham lands on certain issues it
would appear that he's just saying how
he feels and reacting to the situation
as it comes up
so there's on top of the how despicable
it is to feed into rumors it also just
it doesn't even make any sense to me
getting into this because considering
Lindsey Graham is still one of the
senators who is willing to criticize
Trump and has criticized in plenty of
times including as recently as like 12
hours ago all right running through a
few other stories here I want to mention
this before the week is up according to
a recent survey a mayor
can spend nearly half of all of their
waking hours
42% staring at screens like I am doing
right now and like you are doing right
now
so whether TV computer phone whatever
Americans are spending half the day
looking at a screen of some kind and
this of course is not surprising and it
also has a surprising according to eight
to another recent survey a third of all
people say they would not be able to
live without screens it's such an
integral part of their day they can't
imagine life without it
meanwhile a new study from the National
Institute of Health says that kids who
spend a couple of hours a day let alone
half the day but even just say two hours
a day looking at screens tend to score
lower on language tests there have been
many studies of this kind all finding
similar things talking about the
detrimental effects of screen time on
kids and on adults although another
study made headlines recently so there
are studies all over the place going
back and forth but this one rate made
headlines by going against the grain so
reading now from the website science
alert calm
it says leading pediatricians said there
is little evidence that shows screen
time is toxic for children even after
other research suggested that just a few
hours a day could damage developing
brains new guidelines for our guidance
for under 18 year olds from the Royal
College of pediatrics and child health
in the UK said that evidence that time
in front of a screen has a negative
effect on children is quote contested
and that quote the evidence of harm is
often overstated the evidence is so weak
according to the group that it could not
offer parents a guide for how much they
should be limiting their children's
screen time again this doesn't this
doesn't meld with what most studies have
found it also just doesn't track with
our basic common sense of course it's
bad for you
to spend half of your life staring at a
screen of course that's bad for you I
mean to spend half of your day doing
anything is probably not good for you
unless we're talking about breathing
in which case you spent it's probably
spent a little bit more than half your
day doing it but especially something as
as sort of sedentary and lethargic and
passive and unthinking as just sitting
there staring at a screen the effects of
that I think are literally immeasurable
in that it affects you in so many areas
and so deeply that you can't possibly
quantify all of it and I think a lot of
the effects it's just it's something
that we notice intuitively we don't even
need all these studies I think we all
know we we can see the effect that if
you spend if you go on some binge with
Netflix and you watch a TV for six hours
how do you feel a feel sprightly and
alive and energetic and do you feel like
you just spent your time doing something
productive do you feel great about it
afterwards no so I think I think just
based on the effect it just just based
on your own experience you know that
it's it's not good for you just like you
don't really need anyone to tell you
that scarfing down a whole Cinnabon at
the airport in 2.5 seconds before you
board a flight isn't good for you you
don't need plenty of people will tell
you that but you don't need them to
because you just know based on how it
makes you but the moment you take that
last bite you're going oh wow that was
not yeah I really wish I just had a
smoothie or something like that or maybe
some baby carrots so it's the same sort
of thing and it's not hard to see why
because as I said watching a screen is a
passive experience it is it is passive
but then also superficially stimulating
and fast-paced so that and this is why
it's so bad for kids and this is why
also why kids shows these days are so
obnoxious most of them because there's
just so it's just so there's so many
things going on and so many different
colors and sounds and noises and
everything just bombarding a kid's face
but it's it's that
way for most of us when we watch most of
stuff on TV or whatever you're doing
it's just you're you're having all of
these things pounded into your brain
while you just sit there comatose
ingesting it unthinkingly and the effect
is that you you get lazy intellectually
because you're not using your brain
you're your brain is being used rather
than you using it now okay you might say
it is possible to actually engage
intellectually with something on a
screen you could read a book on a tablet
so that's perfectly fine
or you could read a challenging article
or essay or something again you know
that's that's great and there are even a
few shows and movies you could watch
that have some real depth to them some
real substance that are really
intelligent and artistic and and I think
maybe you could become smarter by
watching them or at least you could
become not Dumber
because these are shows or films that
function more like novels and that
really challenge you and make you think
and are not handing everything to you
you know they're not spoon-feeding
everything to you and they're not
pounding your brain constantly with with
with with stimuli you know with with
stimulation but the vast majority of the
entertainment on your screen is not like
that the vast majority and we all know
it is aggressively aggressively stupid I
think this every time I'm watching
football which of course watching
football is a completely mentally
engaging thing to do and it makes makes
us all smarter right or maybe not but
whatever but if I'm watching it and and
then I see a commercial like I'm
watching a football game of Fox or
something or on CBS or whatever and then
I see commercial for the new slate of
broadcast sitcoms that are coming out
this season every time I see these
commercials for these sitcoms I sit
there and just after watching a
30-second spot for a sitcom I really
feel
like my IQ has collapsed just in those
30 seconds it is so so so so stupid and
mind-numbing that I practically lapse
into a coma just by half a minute of
exposure and I always think and I make
the same point about to my wife if she's
in the room every time we see one of
these commercials I always say like who
watches this stuff
who is sits down I I can't even stand a
30-second commercial who is sitting down
on your average Tuesday night and saying
I'm gonna watch stuff like this for two
three hours I can't even imagine it I
mean lord help a lord help them have you
ever noticed something have you ever
noticed how if you sit down to read a
book at like 9:30 at night you'll get
really really tired and within the hour
you're ready to go to bed right which is
one of the excuses people will always
give me for why they don't read is I
love to read but it makes me tired okay
well maybe it's not such a bad thing to
be tired at the end of the night you
know maybe that's a good thing you might
as well say well you know I'd love to go
for a jog but it makes me tired yes
that's the point that's part of the
point it's good that it makes you tired
that's a good thing so and I've noticed
this myself so if I sit down I read a
book that night yeah it does make me
tired and then I'm gonna probably be
going to bed a lot earlier than I
normally would but if it's 9:30 at night
and I sit down and I put on the TV I
could be up until 3 o'clock in the
morning I mean it's I'm not going to get
tired why is that because the book is
working your brain it's tiring you out
it's making you think whereas the show
on the other hand is catatonic it puts
you into this kind of mental stasis or
stupor and then you just sort of Coast
mentally psychologically not asleep not
awake and and I think that's one of the
reasons why people complain about you
know having trouble sleeping these days
so it seems like everyone is claiming to
be claiming to be an insomnia I guess
because you're sitting there you know
watching the TV
a lot of people have TVs in their room
so they they get down and they lie down
in bed they put on the TV and then
they're there you know they can't figure
out why they can't sleep and okay maybe
it you know it's it's fine sometimes to
watch some really stupid thing that puts
you into a mental stasis but every day
for hours that can't be good for you
it's the same thing if you sit there you
know if you're sitting there in bed
which I've done this plenty of times but
if you're sitting there in bed just
mindlessly you know scrolling through
social media and you could sit there for
five hours and do this and not even
notice it because again it's shutting
your brain off which maybe sometimes
that's fine but half the day every day
every night no and this is why I am a
big proponent of books
I think books are great I wish more
people read books I wish I should read
books even more than I do
if you just get yourself into the habit
of reading and it it'll be kind of tough
at first I think but if you get yourself
into the habit and you make that your
relaxation time you just you say to
yourself I'm this is gonna be my time to
relax it's gonna be no I'm not watching
TV I'm reading a book and at first yeah
it's gonna be a little tough because
it's so easy to just put on the TV and
shut the brain off completely but if you
try to force yourself to read force
yourself to like it develop an interest
in it fine books figure out what kinds
of books interest you and and stock up
on those and then and then and then
maybe you'll eventually you look forward
to it make it a whole thing right if you
have a fireplace but the fireplace aw
and you sit there you get a drink you
got to drink something when you're
reading that's you can't you can't enjoy
a book unless you're drinking something
for me it's whiskey maybe for you it's
wine it doesn't have to be alcohol could
be tea could be coffee if you're the
kind of person who can drink coffee at
night but you need some kind of relaxing
drink that you sip on okay so a glass of
water isn't gonna cut you need some kind
of drink you need some sort of thing
like your eat you know you need some
little like reading spot where you
you read and you have your book and you
read and if you do that I think over
time you'll actually begin to look
forward to it and then and I think it
you just it's very you're not gonna
regret spending if you sit down and read
a book for now you're not gonna say
after that oh man I wish I hadn't done
that and I know for me when I get into a
thing where I'm reading a lot I feel
fresher I feel smarter I feel more
engaged with life I also think I'm a
better writer when I'm when I'm reading
during those times so that's what I
would recommend and finally this
dovetails nicely with the last thing I
wanted to talk about I had planned to go
to the mailbag the email answer an email
today on Friday and I found this email
yesterday and I knew that I wanted to
talk about the screen thing and give my
little reading speech so so when I saw
this email I thought this would be a
good one because it kind of worked with
it so someone emailed me a few days ago
said dear Matt assuming that bookshelf
behind you during your show isn't there
just for show can you tell us what are
your top five or six favorite books on
that shelf I could really use some good
reading suggestions no those books are
not actually totally for show some of
them are completely blank they're just
there as decoration no no they're not
for show and I like this question
because it limits me yeah I thought
about maybe I would cheat because it
says what are my top five or six books
on that shelf
I have other books that I like that are
elsewhere in the house and I thought
maybe I would cheat and get but I'm not
gonna cheat so I went I did go to that
particular shelf and found my top five
or six books on that shelf and I'll
share them with you and then here are
some good you know if you if you decide
you want to become a nerd who reads a
lot then here are some good suggestions
for you so five or six quickly from that
shelf here's my first suggest I don't
know if you could say problem of pain by
CS Louis this is not my favorite CS
Lewis book my favorite C Lewis book is a
great divorce which was not on that
shelf so I can't I can't do that but
probably the problem of pain is I think
still see us Lewis at his best where
he's dealing with you know he's dealing
with the one of the biggest problems one
of the biggest issues
for a believer which is how could there
be a God who is overseeing a world with
so much suffering and pain such a
difficult problem one that CS Lewis
takes very seriously obviously but he
deals with it in a way and this is why
CS Lewis was so great is he deals with
in a way that's very accessible there
are a lot of great theologians who you
try to pick them up and read them and
you can't get through a page because you
don't even understand what they're
saying CS Lewis didn't have that problem
he could break down these very complex
deep kind of subjects in a way that even
someone as stupid as myself can
understand then the Solzhenitsyn reader
I mean my favorite Solzhenitsyn book
isn't on the shelf so I'll just give you
this and the great thing about this is
it has has some of his writings from
some of his novels like you know the
Gulag Archipelago but it also cancer
ward it also has his speeches including
the iconic speech that Solzhenitsyn gave
to Harvard and I think 1976 or it was in
the news in the 70s I believe after
Solzhenitsyn was exiled from the Soviet
Union for being such a strong critic of
of that regime he was exiled it came to
the United States he was a hero here he
was invited to give this this
commencement address everybody thought
it was gonna be kind of like this
rah-rah-sis-boom-bah
go USA Stars and Stripes kind of thing
and it wasn't that at all he gets up
there after being exiled from the Soviet
Union he's embraced by the West and he
gets up there and he just offers this
searing indictment of Western culture a
very accurate indictment of Western
culture and so he was hated by people in
the West after that he was just kind of
this man in between aided by everybody
and I think it's one of the great heroes
of the 20th century consider the lobster
by David Foster Walt I think his his his
short story collection supposedly fun
thing I'll never do again is better but
I didn't have that on there I think
David Foster Wallace is my favorite
that I've ever read he's got a great
insight into the human condition he was
not a Christian obviously if you know
his story he died in tragic
circumstances he was a seeker looking
for the truth
and despite the tragic end of his life I
still think that there's a lot that even
a Christian could glean from from his
essays the Lord by Romano Gordini is my
favorites piece of spiritual writing of
all time easily I would recommend that
and then finally I'll go with the
horizon this one this cop is pretty beat
up but the rise and fall of the Third
Reich
William Shire my favorite piece of
history writing that I've ever read as
you can see it's pretty long but it's
just I mean it's absorbing it's
compelling it's terrifying it's
disturbing
but if you really want to understand
what led to World War 2 and more
importantly just how could a guy like
Hitler this started life as just this
obscure kind of vagabond this sort of
you know anti-semitic nutcase radical
who manages to you know become one of
the most powerful men of the other 20th
century and you know threatens to take
over the entire world
how did that happen and how is it that
people fell in line behind this
ridiculously evil man if you want to
understand that which is one of the one
of the great questions of the 20th
century one of the great questions of
history I don't think you could do any
better than reading that book it gives
you such an insight into it you're not
going to go away from that book having a
very cheerful impression of human nature
it's not a cheerful read at all but I
still would absolutely recommend it so
there's some I also had crime and
punishment as Dostoevsky I don't know
there might be Saturn how many I
recommend it but crime and punishment is
Dostoevsky second best book behind a
brothers caramel caramel
in my opinion so there you go if you if
you want to start reading there are some
recommendations for you if you happen to
care again I want to say God bless all
the people at the march for life if you
made it out thank you for for being
there and thank you for fighting the
good fight I'll talk to you on Monday
Godspeed